müsli fragt hattest du schon mal einen
autounfall
lychen meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge hier auf
dem minecraft leben server und zwar
wollte ich diese folge heute mal nutzen
um ein paar kommentare zu beantworten
und wieso habe ich nur so wenig
ungehalten so ich werde jetzt mal eben
da unten von dem feld ein paar karotten
holen das dürfen wir immer machen weil
das kennt er alle zugänglich ist und ich
hatte mir einfach gedacht da ich ja auch
gesagt habe dass ich meine kräfte leben
demnächst auch öfter dafür nutzen werde
dass sich fragen von euch über twitter
die e mail dort gestellt hat beantwortet
werde ich heute zehn fragen einfach mal
beantworten die ich mir aussuchen werde
und dabei werde ich ein wenig an meinem
haus weiterbauen und mir erstmal hier
vorne noch was essen kray erstmal hatten
sehr viele leute gefragt wieso denn
gestern gar kein video kamen die so
allgemein in letzter zeit mal zwei drei
videos täglich kommen dann wieder so
zwei drei tage gar nix und zwar das
einfach derzeit etwas damit zu tun dass
ich lange der klausurphase war ich habe
jetzt allerdings schon so ein paar
resultate also ich hab eigentlich ganz
gute noten gespielt was ich bisher ist
eine wurde wieder das 1 2
dann bin ich eigentlich zufrieden mit
sage ich mal ach so ich wollte gerade
den karotten samt hab ich kann ja auch
einfach so jahr anpflanzen
also es ist dann meistens wirklich so
dass ich dann teilweise mal uni hat von
9 bis 11 uhr also von 9 bis 11 uhr dann
halt nur zwei stunden oder so dann mache
ich danach dann halt zwei drei videos
für einen tag konnte dann mache ich dann
mal öfters so ein paar videos täglich
dann hänge ich mir sogar kommen jetzt
hier richtig bock radio gibt mal macht
man hier so ein paar videos und dann am
nächsten tag habe ich dann wieder so die
ganze zeit um die nahezu alles was ich
mich frage wie soll ich das denn hier
alles nachpflanzen du so viel charakter
ich doch gar nicht doch ich glaube dass
das klappt leider hat geklappt und das
wieder kartoffeln hätten ihm erzählt man
alles mit und dann ist es halt wieder so
dass sich dann beispielsweise mal den
ganzen tag uni haben oder dann
irgendwohin fahren muss und dies machen
müssen dann habe ich dann natürlich
wieder nicht vorproduziert sondern muss
dann schnell wirklich clean anruf muss
dann irgendwo hinfahren und 38 keine
ahnung ganz komplizierte sachen immer
deswegen
ist es zurzeit ein bisschen unregelmäßig
aber ich werde mir jetzt vornehmen erst
mal für eine woche vor zu produzieren
dass ich mal ein bisschen ruhe habe mal
mein ganzes leben wieder planen kann und
danach wird dann also erst produzieren
das heißt die nächsten 10 10 tage ca
habt ihr habt ihr jeden damit es allen
video allerdings wollte ich ja fragen
beantworten und zwar hat mir der liga
del wird werder bremen dieses jahr schon
meister oder erst nächstes lieber will
werder bremen wird leider nie meister
das einzige was er tut es im dfb-pokal
gegen arminia rausfliegen f&e doppel n a
oder so was hältst du von fanseiten auf
facebook twitter und co wo bin ich
ach ich kann erst dann war kann ich hier
nicht einfach ja ich brauche auf jeden
fall ich brauche auf jeden fall kohle
für fackel die ich bin jetzt nicht so
frech und nehme ich ihnen fackel
vektorgrafik noch
ich sind fake seiten alter wo ich bin da
habe ich einfach auf sein haus drauf
erklärt lux nicht richtig klettern immer
noch die die wand hoch oder irgendwie so
ich halte davon recht wenig weil ich
selber schon seiten gesehen hat bei
facebook bei instagram beispielsweise
hatte ich ja nur ach ich werde hier so
schnell welche in diesem von dem bieten
blog binder vorne das ist auf jeden fall
ganz nahe bei instagram war es damals so
dass ich ja den kontrast account hatte
da hieß ich bei instagram kontrast dann
habe ich mich umbenannt auf laser luca
weil ich den am laserdrucker irgendwie
ganz cool finde ich habe im briefkasten
liebe mitbürgerinnen ich biete seit
neuestem freiwilligendienst an wofür ich
ressourcen also wenn ich zum beispiel
ein projekt planen aber keine zeit habe
die ressourcen dort komme ich ins spiel
wird sie schreiben mir ein buch wo
drinsteht was sie haben wollen und wann
dieses boot tun sie dann meinen
briefkasten am leuchtturm steht das
würde mich freuen wenn du den dienst in
anspruch nehmen der dienst steht ihnen
immer von freitag bis sonntag zur
verfügung
okay vielleicht welcher darauf
zurückkommen aber ich denke mal dass ich
mit meiner ressourcen
es ist nett aber ich glaube dass ich
auch noch hin auch dieser schaden ich
hatte damals diesem account der einfach
so hieß wie mein youtube annahme
allerdings dann habe ich mich halt
laserdrucker genannte dann weil dieser
kontrast account direkt hat sich den
infekt gekrallt fand ich halt nicht so
geil und das ist einfach mal weiter zu
fake seiten ich verstehe es nicht
man findet damit keine freunde und
welches nicht geholt das ist sogar meine
ich in daegu wenn man ein patent auf
seinen namen angemeldet habt aber das
habe ich nicht alles eine sache gebe die
du in deinem leben ändern könnte es was
wäre es von this is no nie wenn ich
etwas ändern könnte ich suche mir
übrigens gerade wieder so nebenbei
einfach fragen raus
viele denken wir dass wir die vorlage
aus suche ich denke einfach nur so
nebenbei einfach ein bisschen twitter
deswegen hab ich das ihr beispielsweise
auch einfach hier mit dem handy so die
ganze zeit da ist und dann antworte ich
da auch direkt drauf deswegen habe ich
mir jetzt noch keine gedanken gemacht zu
einer sache die ich mich nicht mögen tun
sein haben luca kanal brings mache ich
mir gerade nur wieder diesen ganzen ton
weil ich sauer putz brauche ich mach mir
erstmal drei stück
und ich glaub brauchen laufen verlauf
ich brauche blumen und zwar nicht nur
gelbe sondern auch noch eine rote das
heißt ich nehme jetzt einfach mal die da
vorne von rechts grundstück ich hoffe
man nicht das reh wieder hingesetzt hat
sondern die blumen dort einfach so
vorhanden war
ul freunde also jetzt ohne spaß wenn es
irgendetwas in meinem leben was sich
ändern würde dann dann hätte ich glaube
ich schon längst geändert weil
eigentlich kann finde ich man kann ja
alles ändern außer wenn man jetzt
irgendwie ich weiß nicht körperlich
behindert ist oder oder weiß ich nicht
weil wenn man mit sich unzufrieden ist
kann man ja eigentlich alles ändern also
wenn man sagt ja meine haare sind wie
geht man zum friseur sagt wie man die
haare haben möchte wenn man sagt ja
meinen arm tut weh da geht man zum
doktor oder auch wenn man wenn man sagt
ja ich finde ich habe keine freunde dann
dann ist man einfach nett und sucht sich
so freunde
ich finde man kann man kriegt alles
irgendwie hin im leben deswegen ich
selber was macht diese spinne hier was
will diese spinne
also ich finde man kann auf jeden fall
in seinem leben alles so ändern dass man
selber sagt und dass ich das mal
zufrieden mit seinem leben ist deswegen
finde ich man man man braucht eigentlich
gar nicht irgendwie mit gegend etwas
unzufrieden sein also ich bin eigentlich
ganz
ich würde nichts in meinem leben so kurz
gefasst roko fragt was fällt dir beim
autofahren am schwierigsten
eigentlich nichts also ich fahre sehr
gerne auto ich fahre auch ausfuhrseitig
16 noch drin also dieses begleitete
fahren dingsbums neben seit ich 17 bin
17 begleitetes fahren das habe ich auf
jeden fall noch mitgenommen so weil ich
unbedingt auto fahren wollte weil ich es
mag wenn man fertig habe es ja nicht so
als ich habe schon ein bisschen von
autos so wer welches modell herstellt
und was mir gefällt und was ps sind und
hubraum und newtonmeter und was weiß ich
alles aber ich bin jetzt halt nicht so
einer der einem die kompletten
einzelteile eines motors vorstellen kann
aber ich finde autofahrer eigentlich
nicht schwer und was glaube ich
eigentlich sonst keiner mag ist einfach
vor allem auch richtig cool dieser
briefkasten er steht ja gar nicht im weg
liebe es großstadt zu fahren die meisten
sagen echt sah großstadt fahren
totales chaos das könnte ich ja gar
nicht und so aber es ist halt wirklich
so ich mag ich mag großstadt fahren und
ja keine ahnung das ist es heißt ihr was
freunde ich setze im briefkasten einfach
hierhin herstellt dann sind sich jeder
schild in kraft dann so kontrovers
briefkasten seitdem der steht mein
briefkasten die also ich mit dem auto
von eigentlich nicht schwer ich finde es
zwar noch spaß und
wird mir beispielsweise auch die
automatik holen weil ich genau automatik
fahnderin gina fragt wenn du einen
zettel hättest auf dem sein todesdatum
stehst würdest du ihn öffnen
ja ich würde ihn auf jeden fall öffnen
weil ich das gerne ich bin bei so etwas
immer extrem neugierig bin auch extrem
neugierig wie überhaupt der tod ist und
so was alles also das heißt jetzt nicht
dass ich unbedingt sterben will um das
herauszufinden oder so aber wenn ich so
ein brief hätte wo drinsteht man nicht
sterben könnte ich mein leben
dementsprechend planen dass wenn ich
schon schon ganz cool deswegen ist es
auf jeden fall der nicht so ein brief
hätte würde ich den auf jeden fall
aufmachen will machst du auch noch ein
video zu hashtag wir einander an alle
die es nicht kennen wir einander ist
eine kampagne der techniker krankenkasse
halte ich herr krankenkassen kasse ich
weiß gar nicht genau wie die heißen und
darstellen halt bestimmte leute ich
meine sogar nur youtube waren da bisher
dabei oder auch noch andere ich glaube
sogar noch andere ich bin mir nicht so
sicher stellen davor wenn sie
irgendwelche schicksalsschläge im leben
hatten übrigens falls ihr euch fragt was
ich hier machen ich baue hier gerade so
ein bisschen ein haus weiter also ich
habe mir nebenbei ein paar gedanken
mache ich mir immer deswegen war
zwischendurch zum verkauf nein also wie
ich das ganze hier bauen werde und da
überlege ich jetzt halt man die ganze
ein bisschen deswegen hab ich noch mal
diesen sandstorm gemacht und die
flowerbox weil ich dachte mir so ich
könnte ja hier ein theo bekommst härter
kleingärtner muss hier wieder muss ich
hinten rum laufen da kommt zum beispiel
ist gleich noch ein fenster rein und so
deswegen hab ich noch ein bisschen glas
hier noch übrig gelassen und ein paar
sachen ich mache mir schon ein paar
gedanken nicht weil sie denkt hier da
kommt keine folge heißt es nicht dass
sie mich nicht damit beschäftige
obwohl ich mich wirklich nicht damit
beschäftigt hat wegen klausuren und
sowas allem aber es ist ja gut gelaufen
jetzt die klausuren ja auch erstmal
vorbei also ich wurde nicht gefragt von
der techniker krankenkasse ich wüsste
jetzt auch nicht dass da irgendwas
einmal ein netzwerk ging weil es wenig
gefragt wurde und wenn dann wüsste ich
aber auch nicht was ich da berichten
könnte das einzige was mal war war
ich hatte wirklich nie sowas so was
richtig krass dass ich sage ich saß mal
im rollstuhl oder ich war dies oder das
aber es gibt wirklich nichts wo ich in
meinem leben tage das hat mich krass
mitgenommen dieses ereignis deswegen
wusste ich da jetzt auch gar nicht genau
was ich da vorstellen sollte es wird
jetzt vielleicht komisch an und ist
jeder macht schicksalsschläge durch aber
ich denke wenn man so einmal offen
moment prob sagt dass das schlimmste
ereignis im leben war dann fällt es
nahezu gar kein oder habt ihr
irgendwelche schlimmen ereignisse ich
meine ich möchte euch dich nicht sagen
jetzt ja erklärt mir doch mal was in den
schlimme ereignisse oder so von eurer
seite das möchte ich natürlich nicht
zutrauen nicht weiß wie viele wollen zum
beispiel über solche sachen auch nicht
reden aber wenn ihr mir sowas sagen
möchte oder wenn die linken das ereignis
hat was ihr aber jetzt sagt ja das ist
jetzt doch nicht mehr so schlimm wenn
ich jetzt darüber reden und so dann
würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr mir so
was mal anvertrauen würde also um die
frage zu beantworten
ich habe noch keine info dazu ob ich an
so was auch teilnehmen möchte und wenn
dann müsste ich mir echt gedanken machen
aber was ich dort berichtet weil das
ganze ist eine ganz coole kampagne aber
ich wüsste jetzt halt zum beispiel nicht
wirklich was ich da sagen würde um die
frage wie weit ein zeugnis /
schulnachricht services schulnachricht
ist weiß ich jetzt gar nicht so genau
wie findet ihr das eigentlich dahinter
kommt an meinem haus so rein und dann
kommt mein haus in dem ich studiere ja
und da bekommt man kein zeugnis sondern
bekommen halte ich begonnen drei jahren
meinen verweis auf den bachelor dass ich
da meinen bachelor mit 130 oder 2,2 oder
so bestanden habe
und das ist es dann noch quasi schon ich
hatte jetzt nur halt diese klausur
geschrieben wo ich jetzt weiß dass die
eine klausel über der dachte das ist
richtig scheiße wird habe ich jetzt mehr
2 also bin ich ganz zufrieden mit
dann habe ich halt eine facharbeit
geschrieben wo ich auch denke dass die
richtig gut ist und ich habe noch ein
anderes fach geschrieben wo ich denke
das ist auch richtig gut war
ich werde euch natürlich die noten sagen
wenn ich die habe und
sonst habe ich halt nicht bekommen weil
ich halt studiere hast du jemals irgend
einen wettbewerb gewonnen fragt der
knoten ist eine interessante frage
mit wettbewerben jetzt klar man hat
fußballturniere gehabt die man teilweise
gewonnen hat man hatte wir hatten auch
damals von der schule aus von so einen
komischen wettbewerb der gießkanne
wieder hieß irgendwas mit mit aktien
oder so dass man da man hatte so
spielgeld und konnte damit an der börse
handeln und konnte sie aktien kaufen
das hatten wir vier jahre lang und da
waren wir glaube ich viel in allen vier
jahren irgendwie immer entweder erst da
oder irgendwie zweiter oder so also das
lied immer richtig guter hat sich immer
ganz gutes händchen bzw wir als team und
echten erfolg erzielt schmiedekunst hat
mir immer ich bin ganz gutes händchen da
hat man dann auch immer richtig
preisgeld gewonnen also wenn man einmal
da so gut warum hat kriegt man schon so
500 euro als team so schon als geil und
sonst wettbewerber klar wir hatten
damals auch so eine tipp gruppe wo man
halt immer so
die bundesliga gezittert und so da habe
ich dann auch manchmal so mitgemacht
aber sieht wirklich bewerbe weiß ich gar
nicht mehr
ich hab auch irgendwann damals mal den
känguru wettbewerb gewonnen das wasser
watet ist dann habe ich irgendwie einer
achten klasse oder so gewonnen da konnte
ich am schnellsten kopfrechnen ich habe
den größten känguru sprung geschafft das
heißt bei samba zu test dass man die
meisten fragen hintereinander nicht
beantwortet hat das waren in 720 oder so
oder 17
ich weiß nicht mehr genau keine handlung
mit wettbewerbsfragen harlow winter
cracker wo mit einem essen ja ja ja ich
hab ich gar kein essen danke ich kann
mein brot jetzt ja eigentlich mal im
ofen backen
ich brauch nur einfach mal kohle ja luca
takt ein brot da rein
ich habe zum beispiel auch einfach nur
kartoffeln und keinen pro woche ce halte
es wird einfach schon wieder nacht das
heißt ich nehme schon wieder 17 minuten
auf sonnemann jetzt verstellen die
nächsten fragen müsli fragt hattest du
schon mal einen autounfall
ich hatte jetzt so direkt noch kein auto
unfall aber ich war heute mega kurz
davor bin eigentlich echt ein fahrer der
jetzt ich bin nicht so einer der so über
die autobahn schleicht sage ich mal aber
ich bin jetzt auch nicht so einer der da
so übel nahezu so ein kamikaze fahrer
ist wenn ihr versteht was ich meine
rolle ich werde das jetzt einfach mal so
ein bisschen so ein bisschen wilder
gespalten ich werde das jetzt mal so ein
bisschen bisschen ja bisschen wilder
gestalten dass die tiere ein bisschen
daran denke wohnten peter jordan drin
oder nico dann kommt hier zwischen noch
sowas
dann mache ich hier noch ein bisschen
war es dass man denkt wow das ist ja
ganz schön verwildert wer will da dann
schon drin wohnen und so und dann machen
wir hier noch was hin hier dass man
denken dass herr unten
da macht ihr da unten noch eben diesem
komischen kauf mir weg also ich war
heute im kino in dem film shame ex was
übrigens ein selbst bruder film ist das
ist ein kinderfilm aber der so witzig
alter das ist genau mein humor da kann
ich ja versucht holt oder lachen und da
bin ich hingefahren mit dem auto mit
einer freundin und dann zu vier ihr
kennt das vielleicht wenn ich zeit war
ebenfalls kurz wenn man hier ist und man
fährt so wenn hierzu der bürger hier so
der sonst eher streit müsse man wie zu
ab und will so zu dem zebrastreifen
hinfahren und dann dachte ich so ja okay
da hinten kam so ein typ und dann der
kam so ganz langsam rüber dann hast du
ja okay ich schaffe das doch davon dann
auf einmal kam von hier von der seite so
ein typ keine ahnung wieso ein dieb so
schnell ist er gelaufen kam so an und
ist so ganz schnell bei die über die
ampel rüber über die thema schreiben
dann muss die vollen die bremsen g20 den
voll ungeputzt war jetzt wirklich den
richtigen unfall nicht verwickelt hatte
ich glaube ich noch nicht ich hatte nur
ein passiv also mein vater fährt richtig
liegt wie viel beruflich auto also
wirklich extrem viel der lebt quasi auf
der autobahn und wir sind damals in
urlaub gefahren und wir waren es schon
spät dran und alles möglich und dann
hatten uns eine halt die vorfahrt
genommen ist mir so in die seite
reingefahren und mir ging es gut als die
tür bisschen eingeklemmt ich hatte mein
ganzes pläne hand und hat pokémon
gespielt und erst das ganze auto
geflogen jetzt kaputt gehen kann
aber sonst nichts passiert aber so einen
richtigen und fertig meinte es tut mir
leid aber ich kann wirklich mich nicht
darauf konzentrieren hier gleichzeitig
zu bauen welche die fragen zu
beantworten und noch hier irgendwie
versuchen euch zum gehalt deswegen
machen wir jetzt einfach noch in der
letzte frage und ich werde das dann im
stream irgendwann mal weiter hier bauen
und 2
ja ich finde es sieht eigentlich schon
mal schon ein bisschen schöner ausnahme
mit diesem teil das passt ganz gut auch
das ist ein bisschen verbittert ist den
weg werde ich ihr dann noch ein bisschen
schöner baum habe ich eigentlich noch
diese komischen
hab ich nicht letzte frage von jonas
hast du lust mal wieder eine neuerung
tour schrägstrich set up tour zu machen
da hätte ich bock und zwar mache ich
also im september ab am ersten september
mich frei das ist in 6 6 7 monaten oder
so und davor wollte ich auf jeden fall
noch eine roompot von meiner wohnung
hier in hamburg machen weil ich ja nach
köln ziehen und da bin ich zurzeit immer
anschauen und wenn man von hamburg nach
köln fesseln dass fünf stunden autofahrt
deswegen post sich oft bei twitter ja
heute kommt ein video ist er sechs
stunden im auto blablabla das ist dann
immer so ein bisschen blöd
jedenfalls wollte ich dementsprechend
vorher noch mal ein video machen hier
wie das hier aussieht mit meinem setup
und vielleicht eine room to respect
privat aber was haltet ihr davon wenn
ich einfach mal mein ganzes set up
nummer vorstellen dass ich dinge
verändert haben ich habe neue soft boxen
ich habe neues neues mischpult ich habe
einen komplett neuen bildschirm mit dem
ich mega zufrieden bin und noch ein paar
andere sachen was davon wenn ich einfach
mal in der nächsten zeit davon sonst
hätt abtue machen würde würde dir da
sagen ja kein schwach wird der stall
letzten schon gemacht hat würde ich
sagen oder lieben freunde war es auch
schon für diese voll gemeinschaft leben
es ist gerade schon wieder 12 uhr und
ich muss morgen um acht uhr aufstehen
muss es jetzt verschneiden dann kriege
ich vielleicht wieder ein paar minuten
schlaf da würde ich mich auf jeden fall
freuen wenn eine bewertung dalassen
würdet und wir sehen uns in einem
nächsten video wieder schreibt die
kommentare der sektor ich liebe übrigens
diesen saft wenn wegen einer meiner
freude machen möchte hohes c roter
multivitamin bester saft